i've pre-drawn some molecules here let's
see if we can use what we know to name
them
so what do we have this first molecule
right here i have a bunch of rings this
is a one two three four five six carbon
ring these are each four carbon rings
one two three four one two three four so
the largest ring is essentially going to
be our backbone so it's going to be this
six carbon ring right here one two three
four five six carbons so that is a
cyclohexane
cyclohexane all double bonds that's why
we get the ain six carbons hex it's in a
cycle cyclo and then we have two of
these four carbon rings so four carbons
we dealing with the prefix butte
butte for four and we've got two of them
so both of these are
butyl groups
both of these are butyl groups
both of these are butyl groups but
they're in a cycle so they're actually
cyclobutyl groups
cyclobutyl
cyclobutyl and we have two things
attached to this ring right there and if
you only had one thing attached to it
you wouldn't have to number when you
have two things you start numbering at
one of them so let's say we start
numbering here and you go in the
direction so that the next group has the
lowest number so in this case we want to
go in the counterclockwise direction if
we went this way it'd be one two three
four five this guy would be a five if we
go in the counter clockwise would be one
two
three this guy will only be a three so
this right here we have two cyclobutyl
so it's dicyclobutyl
it is dicyclobutyl
dicyclovu
till we have two of them and they are at
the
one and three
positions at the one and three position
i have two cyclobutyls on my cyclohexane
i guess you could call it main
ring let's try this one right here so i
have a five carbon ring one two three
four five right there and then i have a
see one two three four five six carbon
ring right there so this is going to be
the main ring that is a cyclohexane
cyclohexane has six carbons on them in a
cycle all single bonds and attached to
that i have a cyclopentyl
group yl for the group so this is a
this is a cyclopentyl
pentyl group on it we don't have to we
don't have to number it because it's
only one group attached to the main ring
if there was another group we would have
to number it like we did up here so this
is cyclopentyl that's this part right
here cyclopentyl attached to cyclohexane
cyclopentylcyclohexane
now let's try this one over here so the
first thing we want to do this is
there's no cycles here but we have to
identify the longest chain
to do that let's just count it out it
could be one two three four five six
seven it's not the longest chain maybe
it's one two three four five six seven
eight that looks like the longest chain
so let's make that the longest chain
let's make that the longest chain right
over there
make that the longest chain and we want
to start numbering in the direction so
we encounter the first attached groups
first so we do want to start numbering
down here because we have groups
attached right on the two carbon if we
started over here we'd have to go pretty
far until something's attached so we go
one
two
three
four
five six
seven
eight so we know we're dealing with an
octane all single bonds it's not a
cyclooctane it's not in a cycle so we
know we're dealing with an octane
we know we're dealing with an octane and
now we just have to add the groups to it
so what do we have here
what do we have here this right here is
just one carbon attached to the main
chain this is another carbon attached to
the main chain so both of these right
here are ethyl gr sorry our methyl
groups
meth is for one carbon those are methyl
groups now we have if you look at all of
them these are the only methyl groups
these two up here aren't methyl groups
so we have two methyl groups on our
entire chain so it's going to be
dimethyl and their both of the methyl
groups are at our two positions so this
is going to be two
two dimethyl this part right here is 2 2
that right there is 2 2 dimethyl we're
going to decide what order to write in
what we after we figure out what these
are called because it has to be in
alphabetical order so this is 2 2
dimethyl the whole chain is an octane
what are these over here
well these how many carbons how many
carbons do we have here one two three
they actually look the same we have one
two three here we have one two three
there so these are both propyl groups
these are both propyl groups
propyl groups and if we deal with common
names this is kind of that y shape you
could call it secropyl because this
carbon right here that's attached to the
main chain is attached to two other
carbons but the more common one because
this part forms this y shape is
isopropyl
it's isopropyl and we have two isopropyl
groups these are both
isopropyl so we would want to call this
let me
actually so we have two isopropyl groups
so we would have
diisopropyl let me write this
diisopropyl
diisopropyl and they're occurring at the
four and five positions two isopropyls
at four and five so this is four and
five
diisopropyl that's that group and that
group right there are accounted for with
this now we have to just figure out the
order that we write it in you ignore the
die or the tri out front and you just
look at them in alphabetical order so we
have an i for isopropyl we have an m
for methyl let's write the isopropyl
first and i've actually seen some people
want to go for the p but i'll
the main thing i ignore is just the die
or the try in front of the isopropyl you
shouldn't involve that but everything
after that you do involve so i'll write
the isopropyl i'll write the isopropyl
first i comes before m so this is going
to be
if we were to write the whole thing this
is going to be
diisopropyl
isopropyl
2 2 dimethyl
two
two actually this should be a comma here
four comma five let me scratch that out
four comma five diisopropyl two comma
two
dimethyl
dimethyl octane
octane
octane and we're done but this was just
the common name you might remember that
you know when you do with iso or sac or
tert
butyl or propyl or whatever that's the
common name if we want the systematic
name
we can look at
the we could start at where we are
attached to the main chain and view that
as one and then make the longest chain
with that as one and so you could say
that we have a chain there and this
would be both of these cases
so this is one two carbons two carbons
we're dealing with an ethyl
we're dealing with an ethyl and on the
first carbon you have a methyl attached
to it
so you could also call each of these
groups a one
one
methyl
ethyl instead of an isopropyl so you can
either say isopropyl for each of these
groups or you could call each of them a
methyl ethyl if you do systematic naming
now you can't well you don't we have two
of these one methyl ethyl groups just
like we had two isopropyl groups if
using common naming you can say
diisopropyl to say you have two of these
groups when you're using systematic
naming you don't say di1 methyl ethyl
although that probably would get the
point across you use bis so this is
since we have two of them instead of
writing instead of writing die you write
bis
you write bis
one methyl ethyl that means you have two
of these things right there and still
and the four in the four and the five
position and if you look at it in
alphabetical order now
methyl ethyl comes after methyl right so
the order will now change so now if you
want to write it with systematic naming
it would be written as 2 2
dimethyl
dimethyl that's these two guys two two
dimethyl ethyl and then you would write
this guy so the order changed for the
two groups just based on how they're
named
this
and then over here you have two
one methyl ethyl groups i know it's
confusing when you just break it down it
actually makes a reasonable amount of
sense
one do you have two of these methyl
ethyl groups oh sorry i forgot where
they're located
so we have them at the four and five
position
so in the four
and five position
four
and five position we have
two
so
this we have two
this
one
methyl ethyl groups
methyl ethyl i know it's a little
daunting now but it all makes sense when
you break it down at men methyl ethyl
groups and then we can just add the
octane at the end
octane let me scroll over to the right a
little bit
octane and we're done now this might
seem more confusing but when you break
down it makes sense we have octane as
the backbone
we have two methyls they're both sitting
on the two positions so you have two
methyls sitting on the two position and
then you have two one methyl ethyl
groups sitting at the four and five
positions in the four and five position
one methyl ethyl one methyl ethyl you
have an ethyl and in the one position
you have a methyl so that's all it's
saying or
you another way to think about it just
in case this doesn't confuse you enough
you could call it that or you could say
four comma 5 diisopropyl
these two things are the same thing
common naming systematic hopefully you
found that useful